[Applaudissements]
après frac et à la meilleure mais c'est
le bouder times bouder sur la c1 mais
c'est un mec qui veut gagner dosé il
réfléchit dit comment je vais faire pour
gagner de l'argent
ouais et un matin il se réveille dit
c'est beau je sais ce que je vais faire
je vais vendre des bibles bible dit mais
je vais pas les vendre moi je suis pas
un bon vendeur je vais organiser un
casting et je vais je prends deux mecs
pour les ventes
donc il arrive dans son casting a que
deux personnes qui sont venues un bègue
est un mec qui parle normalement
auraient dit madiba je vous embauche
façon la personne d'autre je vous
embauche un mois après le mec qui parle
normalement a vendu 5 bible et lebègue
il en a vendu 27 waouh c'est pourquoi
fort unités il appelle le bain qui dit
comment tu fais toi pour vendre kevin et
due forme au toque à la porte on ouvre
jeudi bon bon bon bon bon bon bon soir
est-ce que je vous vous vous est-ce que
je vous vends une bible où je vous lis
un passage
bon
c'était la première du goût des retards
il démarre très sage l'adorent well et
bien je la dra j'adore que tout allait
bien en face aux blues on s'est dit
alors je vous ai jamais parce que
d'habitude d'un explique les blousons et
les vols ou à moi ou à jamel et là c'est
vous non c'est encore un vol non la
nouvelle j'ai été chercher mon fils à
l'école il avait un petit qu'ils
accrochent une deuxième pour le bouder
times et l'autre à trois de suite
j'avais trois dessinateurs times et
après on va faire qui n a plus qu elle a
commencé fort le niveau est très haut
c'est un mec il n'arrive pas à dormir il
dort pas toute la nuit il dort pas une
marche dans son salon april march é il
rend fou et sa femme est en train de
dormir
ils empêchent sa femme de dormir
tellement elle n'était pas bien et ce
afin d'abandonner révèle jury qu'est ce
qui t'arrive tu avais déduit qu est ce
qui m'arrive kitty qu'on est gay on est
dimanche dire oui et alors les débats
demain ce lundi
oui mais alors ça va pas changer ça
libère demain lundi on est le vin et du
oui le vin et loue le problème des
balles le 20 tu sais très bien que je
dois rendre deux cent mille euros à mon
voisin michael qui en face le dit alors
l'image les ai pas je n'arrive pas à
dormir et sa fameuse ya tant à la toque
à la fenêtre alors ouvert sa fenêtre à
la criée michael médical le guen quoi me
dit mon mari doit donner deux cent mille
âmes un annuaire nibali les appâts à la
ferme et apporter 10 dans maintenant
celui qui va pas dormir
[Applaudissements]
dernière après bien sûr ton fera
d'autres dans la soirée mais un contenu
mais si vous êtes très bon montant d on
attendait à la jean bernard tout le
monde attendait on attendait john
eledjam et dans ma plein à la c1 mais
qu'il est en train de pleurer ils
pleurent rient pleurent rient pleurer à
son pote il vient de voir et mickaël
pourquoi tu pleures tu pourrais je
pleure ça fait trente ans que je suis
mariée avec la même femme ne dit alors
c'est bien et dire oui mais ça fait 30
ans que une fois par mois
elle demande 680 euros ou tuera [ __ ]
c'est pas possible
mais qu'est ce qu'elle sait que tout cet
argent le dit je sais pas je n'ai jamais
donné
[Applaudissements]